welcome back to the david patten show
benjamin dixon filling in for David
while he is appearing on the Joe Rogan
podcast if you're just seeing this video
soon enough David will be live at 3 p.m.
on Joe Rogan's channel YouTube channel
and if you're watching this video at a
later point then obviously go and watch
the replay I'm sure it's gonna be a
fascinating conversation file this next
video
this next story under being so committed
to your racism that it backfires a 70
year old Ruby Howell has been arrested
she was first fired and then she was
arrested as a result of a video that
went viral that showed her pulling a gun
on two black people as they attended or
tried to find a place to have a picnic
Ruby nelle how is a 70 year old white
woman and the video really speaks
volumes about so many things that still
have to be discussed today take a look
at the video
this lady literally just poured a gun
because we out here did have
reservations late that we didn't even
know we had to have reservation for we
don't know that I'm done you happy to
tell us we didn't know don't think what
they would tell us to leave we would
have live you did not have to pull a gun
early
with this this all you had to say that's
all you have to say well that's fine
that's fine now I mean it's really
impossible to look at that video and not
discuss it in the broader context of so
many things that are still happening in
this country but very specifically the
history of this country the the
historical baggage the racial baggage
that still exists in this country I mean
it's I have to discuss it in that
context because look at how shockingly
quick this escalated to a
life-threatening situation for this
black couple who basically just went out
to look for a place to barbecue she
pulled a gun because they weren't
supposed to be there well Ruby nelle how
works for that campsite and she no
longer works there but she did and I'm
quite sure that's not the first time
someone came to looking to use their
facilities without an appointment I mean
quite frankly most people when you're
looking for a place to barbecue you look
for a public space and you just go there
and then you find out you know by ok
it's it's just it's it's free to use
that I don't need an appointment or you
need a permit and you need an
appointment but in none of the
situations that I have ever encountered
that it remotely similar to this and I'm
sure for you as well a matter of fact I
would guarantee 99% of everyone
listening probably 100% of everyone
listening
if you encounter a situation where you
showed up somewhere where you needed a
permit or you needed to make an
appointment nobody pulled a gun out on
you to demonstrate that you didn't have
the right to be there but Ruby nelle how
of Starkville Mississippi thought that
that was the right thing to do so not
only does she lose her job but she also
was arrested on for threatening exit for
a threatening exhibition of a weapon she
was she turned herself in and got out on
a whopping five hundred dollar bond now
again I I don't really want to belabor
the point too much but you have to put a
fine point on this fact in some state
she would have been better off if she
had killed that couple and as
inflammatory as that statement sounds
you have to understand states like
Florida and Georgia have Stand Your
Ground laws that allows a person to use
weapons to quote/unquote defend
themselves when they fear for their life
and they have the right to stand their
ground which which really I bring it up
because you have to ask yourself the
question at what point is the
unreasonable and irrational fear of
black people going to be addressed in
situations like this but more
specifically in situations where people
stand their ground because this woman
had literally no reason whatsoever to
fear this couple no reason whatsoever to
pull a gun on this couple but she pulled
it out but I mean for wat'ry I mean she
you have to say she was afraid right you
don't just pull unless you you're
pulling out the gun just to you know
just for a power play well that
backfired for as well but there's an
irrational level of fear that that is
connected to black people and that's
intentional
I mean I can break this down so many
different ways and come to my channel
and I'll do that but that's intentional
like this irrational fear that would
leave this woman to pull a gun on a
couple a married couple not that that
should be a qualifier and then oh if
they're not married or if they weren't a
couple they should have had it no no no
but still it's a you know yeah a married
couple looking to have a barbecue and
this woman either just wanted to show
how bad she was or she had some
irrational fear going on and led to her
pulling the gun out thank goodness she
didn't use it but in so many cases we
see across the country those weapons are
use and people lose their lives because
of this irrational fear that has been
baked into this American society it's
the vilification of blackness goes all
the way back to the justification for
slavery because there had to have be
there had to have been a level of
dehumanization that took place for
people to justify and say oh for
particularly for Christians in this
country to say oh well slavery even
though you know it's okay because
they're not really human it trickles
down through generations it this fear
it's irrational fear I'm gonna get off
this one and just move on to something
funny but this irrational fear trickles
down through the generations and it is
still here today and we see incidents
like this that could really have led to
the death of people for no reason
whatsoever based on some irrational fear
that is baked into this American system